right now what we're going to do you and
I is we are going to watch me watch
videos what a very very dark
humor let's
[Music]
go come on come
on that it's
not come on I'm a trifle deaf in this
year speak a little louder next time
start off with your thoris take a deep
breath a deep breath all right so you
might feel a little
pain take a deep breath let's get your
Q4 and your Q3
and I have a chiro brager buddy who
would offer it to give me a correction
and then I just see him do it to other
people
like no I'm good thanks I like my
[Music]
head that's helpful when you want to
keep track of your friends the
mathematicians would draw the
world they're complying with the Ada
technically but it's it doesn't seem
seems half-hearted rules are rules
Robin
excuse
excus did he Gore him or did he just
catch on I I can't tell if this is this
is a cool Happy video or or very sad
imminently sad hey man can I just get a
water cup
[Music]
yeah a look at the top of his
head is that
water
Sprite you wanted
[Music]
Sprite well shot it was
perfect perfect everything down to the
last simple enough concept but very well
shot I can grab you a
cake he you good man thanks dude yeah no
worries never really subverted my
expectations you think I just told you
to hop for no reason not going to work
again though it the problem it'll work
watch your head going to hit his head
watch your
head no no yeah oh boy I can't believe
just that is not ideal don't laugh
dude I saw that coming from a mile
away hi I'm a serious journalist we do
really important work here on the
Michael nll show I see that
again it's so hard to find a straight
man that is confident enough to
compliment hit me on my
looks nice
balls I don't think those tweets are
real though I I do remember Norm had a
bit on this where he said yeah yeah
Caitlyn Jenner might might be brave you
know but I don't think she's beautiful
you know there aren't a lot of like
65-year-old women who are like super hot
okay how do you do that how did he do
that well good tweet anyway holy cow
[Music]
I was waiting for the next thing in the
joke and then I realized that was the
punch line and that's fair that was good
that was
[Music]
good how you get them to stop clever
teacher clever clever
clever right now go to expressvpn.com
YT it is Christmas time that means it's
the season of giving but you've already
given enough to your internet service
provider if you have not been using
expressvpn when you go online I'm not
just talking about the enormous internet
bill you pay every month every time you
go online without expressvpn your
internet service provider can see and
log every single website that you visit
yes that includes includes all those
websites that you visit in incognito
mode in addition to overcharging you
your ISP is legally allowed to sell all
your browsing activity to thirdparty
advertisers for massive profits I am
done giving that to my ISP I trust
expressvpn the app encrypts and reroutes
100% of network data through their
secure servers so that the ISP cannot
see a thing the app could not be easier
to use I'm a total Lite with technology
and yet even I can use it you just click
one button fire on your devices your
phone your laptop whatever one button
you are connected right now go to
expressvpn.com
Michel YT get three extra months of
expressvpn for free
expressvpn.com
Michel letter Y lettert expressvpn.com
YT to learn more would you like to
donate a dollar to save a dog
no
yes
no oh
god um I think that your machine
is I was just trying to pay
for
[Music]
yes
true that machine is still better than
the tip machines every time you go and
you buy a pack of gum and say would you
like to leave a tip oh don't just just
fill out just fill it out however you
like don't no I'm not even
looking still better three two one get
it
Is that
real ouch where is my tall skinny
liberal emo he's probably around this
corner hanging off the top of the
[Music]
ceiling too real it's too real what is
the dumbest tattoo that you've ever
[Music]
gotten great
right I don't know that I believe
that maybe though people get really
stupid tattoos That's My Credo no
regrets mhm that's really that's great
though you can see this is the evolution
meter and I put God the creator of
everything on the right side an
evolution on the left M look you're
wasting our time you're not going to get
us to not believe in evolution and why
is that because the smartest scientists
in the entire world all agree that it's
real I'm glad you brought that
up Mr Reynolds these were all the
smartest scientists only problem is they
kept being wrong you just read the words
of a bunch of guys that you never met
and you just take it on faith that
everything they wrote was true and what
makes you think what your scientists are
writing is any more truer than my Saints
because there are volumes of proven data
numbers figures have you poured through
the data yourself the numbers the
figures well no I no oh interesting so
let me get this straight Mr Reynolds you
get your information from a book written
by men you've never met and you take
their words as truth based on a
willingness to believe a desire to
accept a leap of O dare I say
it faith
come come on
look he got a few things wrong around
the edges there but broadly speaking
totally correct Mac totally correct uh
this is a cast and a Danish production
which is entirely Nordic it uh therefore
has some lack of diversity you would say
as also new rules are implied in
Hollywood are you on to yeah sorry but
from the Geto from the GetGo there is
said some well first of all the film
takes place in Denmark in the
1750s well yeah but you can't let that
nasty little fact get in the way of
things I'm I'm very excited for the uh
Betsy Ross documentary starring Denzel
Washington look Denzel's a good actor
he' probably do a good job with it but
it is a little weird isn't it there is
some rules of diversity and you don't
live up to these
standards shut up shut up it's not
because of artistic because of diversity
shut up I hope you've enjoyed sitting
here with me watching me watching other
videos of very dark humor see you next
time shut the up